Bethesda announced today that Skyrim
special edition has gone gold meaning
its initial development is complete and
the game is ready for manufacturing it
also provided some new technical details
about the PC and console versions of
Skyrim special edition either way the
game doesn't ask much the high-end only
calls for an i5 2400 on FX 8320 and a
gtx 780 or an r 9 290 none of which are
exactly cutting-edge you'll only need 12
gigs of free hard drive space to go
along with that keep in mind the pc
version is free for anyone who owns the
game and it's 3 DLC packs you can also
buy the dlc packs you're missing edit
discount to get your hands on special
edition on the console side Bethesda
shared the file sizes for ps4 and Xbox
one which are actually much larger than
on PC that's especially true in Europe
presumably due to the need to include
more languages the ps4 version will be
about 20 gigabytes in the US and around
33 in Europe for xbox one it'll come in
around 17 gigabytes for North America
and 25 for Europe Skyrim special edition
launches on October 28 the pc version
supports mods while the console versions
will do so for the first time yes that
includes the ps4 version special edition
also features a wide array of visual
improvements including remastered art
and effects volumetric lighting dynamic
depth of field effects and more those
playing on the ps4 pro and the system
launches next month we'll also be able
to plan for K and in case you're curious
here are the recommended pc specs for
the special edition
for more on Skyrim stay tuned to
gamespot